la noix de coco il a le principal
ressources 3 millions d'arbres les
hommes du clan des coteaux vivent des
richesses de cette forêt les en sont les
cueilleurs mais depuis longtemps il ne
grimpent plus aux arbres ils ont trouvé
dans la nature appartenait idéal le
singe
bourrane a eu des singes toute sa vie
dans le clan des coteaux il est
considéré comme un maître ici un singe
bien dressé et le prix d'un but
[Applaudissements]
avec un singe l'apprentissage par la
récompense ne suffit pas
le singe doit se sentir protégé
le coprah et la chair de la noix de coco
il est moulu pressé et cuit pendant les
heures on en extrait de l'huile et on la
vend au marché le lait sert
d'ingrédients pour la cuisine et
d'aliments pour les bébés
les cueilleurs de noix se déplacent tout
le temps ils vont chez les uns chez les
autres à la demande sur dinoi en prélève
une pour lui les 9 autres reviennent au
propriétaire de l'arbre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les muscles du singe sont contractés
bobo est en plein évolution elle ne sera
adulte qu'à 3 ans Burane veille sur sa
croissance
a lieu un grand concours de cueillette
les jeunes dresseurs préparent leur
singe
[Musique]
on a sorti des couleurs mi-nangues jaune
pour la noblesse rouge pour la gaieté
noir pour la bravoure le jour du grand
concours est arrivé
c'est le moment pour bobo de faire ses
preuves aux yeux du clan Boral veut
qu'elle gagne depuis une semaine il la
stimule sa réputation est en jeu
pour Reina cette compétition va surtout
déterminer la valeur de son singe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est lui qui arbitré la compétition et
maintenant il veut bobo
secret personne ne doit connaître le
montant
n'a pas le cœur à se séparer de bobos
[Musique]
vont encore cueillir quelques noix de
coco ensemble
il ne faut pas séparer les cueilleurs de
ciel